today on the matt wall show the left has
its expected psychotic breakdown in
response to ruth bader ginsburg's death
they're claiming that it would be an
assault on the rule of law
and democracy for republicans to confirm
a replacement before the election
that's completely absurd and laughable
and i'll explain why also five headlines
including the tragic
suicide of a bar owner who was facing
prison
for defending himself against a rioter
who attacked him terrible story there
and in our daily cancellation i will
cancel all airlines and airports after
having to endure their completely
arbitrary coveted regulations last week
all of that coming up
but first a couple of quick notes um the
show today brought to you by
lifelock listen it's bad enough if you
if you get hacked
and your identity is stolen but then
it's even worse because you'll feel dumb
for not having taken precautions ahead
of time especially when taking
precautions is so easy with lifelock
identity theft has become a big time
crime with criminal gangs operating
units dedicated just to that and certain
behavior can make you more vulnerable to
identity theft like
not checking your credit card or bank
statements using the same username and
password on every account
never checking your credit report over
sharing personal information on social
media it's important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives because they're
affecting our lives
in in you know myriad ways every day we
put our information at risk on the
internet
and you could miss certain identity
threats by just monitoring your credit
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number being
for sale on the dark web other things
that you wouldn't be able to
detect yourself if they detect your
information they're going to send you an
alert
and uh and if if there is a problem you
get your identity stolen then lifelock
will be there to help you with that too
there are you know and there are other
basic precautions you can take right
like don't use the same password for
everything
it's not a good idea if all of your
accounts can be accessed with like
password123 or something though at least
those passwords are easy
easy to remember but a good rule of
thumb if your password is easy to
remember
it's easy to hack and even if it isn't
easy to hack you still want life luck
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions
at all businesses but you can find out
if your information is on the dark web
and you could do that by getting your
free dark web scan at lifelock.com
walsh you pick the plan that's right for
you save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
walsh that's a free scan
at lifelock.com walsh and 25 off
with promo code walsh all right one
other uh
important point before we get into the
show what i want you to do right right
after this show not right now but after
the show
is go to youtube.com matt walsh
and subscribe to my personal channel in
a few days all of my
shows and my other content will be on my
channel you won't get it here you have
to go to youtube.com
matt walsh so please make sure to do
that and subscribe by the way this
doesn't mean i'm leaving the daily wire
you won't get rid of me that easily i'll
still be here but my shows
all of the shows all the other hosts too
will be on the individual
channels of the host so you have to go
to youtube.com
matt walsh okay now if you avoid the
internet
and news entirely on the weekend which
by the way if you do good for you that's
a very psychologically healthy practice
if you're in that camp then you may not
have heard that justice ruth bader
ginsburg
passed away at the age of 87. the rest
of us
the rest of the country i suppose is
familiar with that information
now as everyone has had all of the
expected reactions to this news and
so far it has played out exactly as you
would anticipate
i have uh just a few things that i that
i want to say a few a few interjections
first of all and this shouldn't even
need to be said
of course president trump should and
will
nominate a replacement and of course
senate republicans
should confirm that replacement whether
they will is another question
but of course they should there is there
is nothing outrageous
or strange or even notable about doing
that
except in the sense that all supreme
court nominations are notable the fact
that there's an election coming up
is irrelevant there are always elections
coming up
the idea that elected republicans who
were elected precisely for this very
reason
to confirm trump's judicial picks should
just sit on their hands
for the sake of being good sports and
not put another justice on the bench
is absurd it is a position so dumb
so vapid so utterly without substance
that it wouldn't warrant a response if
not for the fact that so many people are
saying it
and so loudly the left obviously is in
the midst of a psychotic meltdown
um well another one or a continuation of
the one they've already been having for
four years
and they're screaming that republicans
you know ramming through a justice at
this point would be an attack on the
rule of law
on democracy on on norms and
worst of all they say it would violate
the dying wish of ruth bader ginsburg
herself
who supposedly said that uh she before
she died that that she wants the next
president to replace her not trump just
for fun here is uh alexandria quezo
cortez
accusing republicans of denying a dying
woman's final wish
listen i need you to be
ready and i need you to be ready to be
responsive and by that
i mean we don't quite know
what the next play is in terms of this
issue on the supreme court right
mitch mcconnell sent out a statement
tonight um
and as i said at the opening
the very last dying wish
of rbg was that her vacancy
not be filled until the new president
takes office
in january that was her dying wish
tonight
mitch mcconnell publicly
the night that she the night of her
passing he couldn't wait
24 hours issued a statement
saying that he was going to
give trump a vote in violation of of her
dying wish
people can say how appalling people
could say this is horrible
etc but we know who this man is
we know who this man is this is a man
who does not care about a dying woman's
final wish
clearly okay now we are a constitutional
republic not a monarchy
we don't bequeath seats according to the
final edicts of a dying woman
i'm sure scalia wished before he died
that the court would be
majority originalist and roe would be
overturned
guess how much the left cares about
scalia's wishes dying or not
the dying wish thing is completely
ridiculous and irrelevant
but the fact that the left is using this
just shows you they are
out of intellectual ammo here they have
no real arguments as to why republicans
shouldn't replace rbg
it's not a violation of the law
obviously the law the constitution
gives them the power to confirm or not
confirm judicial nominees it is entirely
in keeping with the law
it is not an assault on democracy again
the people elected
the people elected these republicans
exactly for this moment
this more than anything else this right
here this is why these republicans
have the power they do right now to do
this
to rise to this occasion what about
norms
well here is alleged uh conservative tom
nichols doing the very conservative
thing of defending the far left position
on msnbc and he's explaining that
confirming a replacement right now
would fly in the face of tradition and
norms
listen it seems to me that um
first of all i just cannot imagine how
most these republican senators
who have gone on the record years ago uh
now wake up and look at themselves in
the mirror and
uh are somehow comfortable with what
they've become
and the things they have to say which is
a purely
the party of power purely the the whole
republican philosophy now is because we
can
uh and i think one of the things that i
find so striking about this
is that it says that conservatives
insofar as we can still call them
conservatives
have completely given up on any hope
that their ideas
can ever be sold to the public that they
can
win um elections that they can
advance their cause they've they have
become the far
left liberals of an earlier generation
saying
uh nobody wants what we're selling so
we're gonna go to the courts
and we don't care how we get to the
courts i mean it is really
it is really amazing to see people of
the right who once
um you know when joe and i were
republicans this was always a big
thing to criticize the left for saying
you know you guys are always going to
the courts
to get things that you can't get at the
ballot box because you don't really
believe in yourselves
and and conservatives have become that
movement now
to say as long as we control the courts
we don't care if you like us we don't
care about the institutions of the
senate
we don't care about norms i mean most of
these senators have said over and over
again constitutionally we are allowed to
do this and that's absolutely right
but the fact the matter is that our our
system operates much more on
norms and traditions than it does on
written law
right they're going to do it because
they can well yes tom
that's how this works they can and they
should
but what about this norm thing is it an
attack on norms for republicans to move
forward with a confirmation right now
three answers to that number one no it
isn't
senators confirming the supreme court
pick of the president who is in their
same party
is the most normal thing in the world
what about 2016 and 2016 the republican
senate
refused to even hold hearings from
merrick garland obama's pick
um did they establish some new norm did
it begin a new tradition that they're
now beholden to
no let me try to put this very simply
for those who don't understand
the reason republicans wouldn't hold
hearings for garland
is that they didn't want garland on the
supreme court
they will hold them now hopefully
because they do want
trump's pick on the court this is how it
works
it's legal it's normal it's operating
within the system
according to how the system was set up
now yes some republicans in 2016
claimed that they weren't holding
hearings because
they wanted to respect the wishes of the
voters in the upcoming election
and yada yada that was a dumb
politically correct talking point
politicians tend to use those kinds of
talking points the reality is they just
didn't want garland on the court
and for good reason there's nothing
sinister about that
it's called using the power you have
it's called playing the cards in your
hand
they did it then they should do it again
now that's what they were elected to do
number two also about norms the liberals
screaming about norms and traditions
are hypocrites they are the hypocrites
these are the people
who tried to block a republican pick by
accusing him of being a serial gang
rapist
and now they want to talk about norms
these are the people who want to get rid
of police departments they want to
abolish the electoral college
they tear down centuries-old statues
they want to blow mount rushmore to
pieces
these are the people who who support
rioting and looting as a political
tactic
these are the people who think it's okay
to put a four-year-old boy in a dress
and pretend he's a girl and now they
want to talk about norms and traditions
give me a break i mean get the hell out
of here it's a farce it's a joke
three my last point about norms
who cares even if this was an attack on
norms which it isn't
but if it was who cares what do i care
what do i care about senate norms why
would anyone care about that we're way
past that now
we are past norms we're past civility
civility is dead the left killed it they
stuff civility in a sack they beat it
unconscious and toss it into the sea
if you're still trying to preserve
civility or be a good sport
you're a fool you're worse than a fool
you're a willing pawn you're a dupe
you're a patsy
you're a [ __ ] and the same goes for any
conservative who argues that the
republicans should tread lightly because
if they don't
democrats when they get into power will
do such and such terrible thing in
retribution
yes of course they will but that's going
to happen no matter what
they've already been cheering on the
destruction of our cities they're
they're encouraging riots they're
stirring a race war
they're trying to keep our economy shut
down they'll do anything at all
anything legal or illegal to seize power
and advance their agenda
the only question is whether
conservatives will finally wake up to
the reality of our culture war and
respond
accordingly let's not lose sight of
something here
why is the left panicking over ginsburg
what is this really about
at bottom they are worried that another
conservative justice
might mean rogue gets overturned and
then their ability to kill babies will
be impeded
this is about killing babies this is
about their infanticidal lust
in case you're wondering if there's a
clear good guy bad guy divide in our
culture
well here it is one side is threatening
to burn everything down in order to
protect its right to murder a million
babies a year
it is not an exaggeration to say
millions of lives hang in the balance
right now
millions of lives republicans have to do
everything in their power
everything in their power to protect and
preserve lives
any cost is acceptable no threat from
the other side should prevent them
let them weep and wail and gnash their
teeth
they're going to do what they're going
to do so be it
now is the time though for the good guys
to do the right thing
and any republican who refuses should be
run out of town in disgrace
there is no room for cowardice or weak
spines
right now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
time is money as they say and uh if you
know you gotta you gotta make sure
you're spending your time
wisely uh just like you should spend
your money wisely and if you wanna spend
time and money wisely go to rockauto.com
you don't wanna go to
sit in a waiting room at a mechanic or
go to the auto parts store
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store
somebody demanding quick answers to
questions they don't have what you need
you got to go online anyway
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the markets will
bear
and you know here's the question it
comes down to why spend up to twice as
much for the same parts i don't see any
good reason to do that
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
reliably low and they've got a great
selection
so you don't you're going to pay twice
as much for uh for
the same parts or or worst of all
they're not going to have the part you
need
so why do that you're paying you're
paying twice as much for a worse
selection
the rockauto.com catalog is unique easy
to navigate
quickly find all the parts you're
looking for for your vehicle
and choose the brands the specifications
the prices you prefer
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts
you're ever going to need tell i'm
telling you it's at rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck write walsh in there how did you
hear about us box
so they know that we sent you all right
by the way i don't know if you can see
it on camera but i do have a um a
bruised lip right here
maybe it probably doesn't come through
but so i don't have to admit to this but
i am admitting that
yesterday i got my ass kicked by um
my 11 month old daughter uh she's not
even one
she's not even one yet and she just
kicked my ass in church of all places
i was holding her and she was thrashing
around head butted me right in the lip
i'm bleeding profusely
in church and uh the moral of the story
is
it was the one time in the last six
months that
the one single time that i was happy
about the mask thing
because i could just put the mask on and
nobody could see my shame i could hide
my shame
but then there's like bloods bleeding
through the mask and that had to look
a little disturbing um all right let's
get to uh
to our news headlines number one as you
can imagine speaking of disturbing
a number of videos have been posted this
weekend of liberals liberal women
specifically
having nervous breakdowns about um rbg's
death
and we're not going to play them all but
i think this one right here that we'll
play this is a good representation
of all the rest of them so watch this
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys
i'm driving your car but i just got a
notification that ruth bader ginsburg
died
could this year get any
ruth you just had to make it to 2021.
just think about the narcissism that's
required to pull out your phone
and take a video of yourself having a
panic attack
because there has to be some measure of
pre-planning here right it's not like
this is
um candidly recorded footage of
no this is this is this is not
spontaneous
so this lady was saying to herself hmm
you know i think i think i'm about to
have a psychotic episode let me uh let
me just pull out the old camera and get
this documented
and then and then she needed to actually
post it right i don't this isn't a
live stream they don't do live streams
on on the old
tic toc do they i don't know but uh so
probably she recorded this and then
watched it back and thought wow this is
my best tantrum yet
this is great content and then she
posted it online for everyone to see
so um that's one sort of genre of
reaction to the
the news of ruth bader ginsburg's death
another genre
this is one of my one of my one of the
most common genres on twitter in general
uh whenever there's a major news event
and i love these this is the thing where
somebody posts
a little anecdote about how their young
child
allegedly reacted to the news um so
once again one example will suffice this
is from a woman named alexandria
alexandra lee capps and she says
uh just told my ten-year-old daughter
about rbg she had tears in her eyes
and then she did the wakanda pose and
said ruth conda forever
which is the sort of pop culture
crossover that i can celebrate
okay first of all that didn't happen
um none of that happened i don't even
think she has a 10 year old
daughter i think the 10 year old
daughter is made up too
i can tell you i told my seven-year-old
daughter that ruth bader ginsburg had
died
and she looked at me blankly and then
went back to her coloring book
that's a more realistic story of course
in reality i didn't tell my
seven-year-old
because she has no idea who ruth bader
ginsburg is or what the supreme court is
because she's seven
and i'm quite happy to keep it that way
personally
um all right let's go on to to number
two here
terrible story a man named jake gardner
committed suicide this week and gardner
was a bar owner a combat veteran in
omaha nebraska
during the riots in may he he went to
his bar to defend
his bar against the rioters because he
didn't want them to burn it down
and when he showed up he was attacked by
one of the rioters named james
scurlock he shot skurlock killed him
this is a a pretty clear case of
self-defense and there is video
of the shooting you can you can well you
could sort of see what happens let's
play that
but this got a gun bro but i got a gun
okay self-defense skirlock had him in a
chokehold and
again the only reason that he was there
that gardner was there was to defend his
business
which he has every right to do now
now what you hear on the left is
basically if you're a business owner
and rioters want to burn it down or loot
the store
then your responsibility is just to let
them do it
because if you show up to stop them and
to protect your livelihood
then you all of a sudden are the bad guy
that's that's what you hear on the left
but that of course is insane
now the d.a donald klein initially said
that this was
this was self-defense and he wasn't
going to press charges
but then after pressure from protesters
in the media
an outs an outside review was ordered
special prosecutor comes in next thing
you know
gardner is charged with multiple
felonies and faces decades in prison
on friday an arrest warrant was issued
for him and then
a day or two later uh he he killed
himself
now they'll call this death a suicide
but it was really a murder
this was a man who was facing the total
destruction of his life
years in prison slandered as a racist
and a murderer
i mean imagine you know think about this
for a second think about going to prison
for let's say 20 years um
and i think he faced more than that a
lot more than that but let's say
imagine facing 20 years in prison
as a racist killer that's how you've
been labeled it's not true but you've
been labeled that way
and now they're going to send you into a
prison for 20 years
imagine that the hell that that would be
especially especially as an innocent man
so it's not surprising that a person
would contemplate
escaping it through through the most
drastic means
available i wish he hadn't of course
but the point is that you cannot do this
to a person
and then react surprised when they
respond in this manner
the d.a in this case is a gutless
disgraceful coward
i hope he feels guilt-ridden over it he
should be
i'm sure most of the leftist protesters
don't have any guilt
in fact they've been celebrating it
because they're soulless but anyone with
a soul should feel outraged
and and and and also real sadness over
this
and also trepidation because you know
this could happen to anybody
if you find yourself confronted by a
crazed mob
and uh you're you're gonna face the same
choice do i defend myself
and then possibly go to prison forever
or do i not defend myself and possibly
get beaten to death
that's a real choice that more than one
person has faced
um number three and the emmys were last
night
that's it that's all i have on that
nothing more to say on that number four
uh this is
this is interesting we talked about the
fact that black lives matter
is a confessed marxist organization with
radical left-wing political views
and uh and and you know ideological
goals and the really handy thing is that
you could go
uh always just go to their website to
blacklivesmatter.com
to the what we believe section and then
you could see what they believe
and so it was always a really easy thing
when it whenever you heard that oh no
black lives matter they're just
they're they're just about racial and
social justice
that's all they care about you could
always respond to that and say
well no go they have a website go to it
and they'll tell you exactly what they
believe
and just read it and if you do that
you're going to see they want to destroy
the nuclear family
they want to get rid of heteronormative
thinking you know they're focused on gay
rights and trans rights
even more than they care about racial
equality
in fact they don't care about racial
equality at all really
so there's all kinds of stuff there but
then recently in the last day or two
the um black lives matter organization
they made some changes to their what we
believe section
let's see what it looks like now
yep it's all gone they deleted the whole
thing they got rid of it
and why did they do it well i don't
think it's a coincidence that right
before the election they get rid of this
um but the really sad thing is this this
will work
won't it like they're just gonna delete
that
and then claimed that it was never there
and so from now on
when you claim for example when you when
you go out and say well black lives
matter wants to destroy the nuclear
family
they're going to say what are you
talking about that's correct it's a good
spirit what is that a q anon conspiracy
theory you kook
that's crazy come on even though it was
on their website right
and it will work it it will work
um number five speaking of blm it
happened again a blm activist in indiana
is the latest white woman to admit that
she was pretending to be black
so the new york post has the story it
says another black activist has admitted
to being a white person
satchel cole hold on a second
satuelle what kind of name is that
satuelle satuelle cole a community
organizer for black lives matter in
indiana
fessed up to the years-long ruse in a
facebook post last week
and vowed to quote seek help cole said
friends i need to take accountability
for my actions and the harm that i have
done
my deception and lies have hurt those i
care about most
i've taken up space as a black person
while knowing i am white
i have used blackness when it was not
mine to use
i have asked for support and energy as a
black person
i have caused harm to the city friends
for the work that i have held so dear
i am sorry for the harm i have caused i
am sorry for the hurt and the betrayal
i will do what i can to show that i want
to be a better person
um and this mayo culpa comes after an
expose published by black indie live
which ran yearbook photos of cole's
white parents and produced documents
showing that cole once listed
her race as white the outlet also
revealed cole's birth name
jennifer benton okay so satuelle cole
was a made-up name
who could have guessed and um
and so on and so forth that goes on from
there so and you can see the picture
this is a what you could this is a white
this is a white woman with a
made-up name i mean anyone can see that
and yet somehow
she got away with this for years um
and it brings us back to the question
why do white people pretend to be black
this keeps happening like every two
weeks now there's another case of it
um and those are just the confirmed
cases we can assume there are a lot of
other you know
supposed black people out there who are
actually white it turns out um
it was we only find out about the ones
who admit to it or or are exposed now
why does this happen because of the
social
advantage it affords them that's why a
white person would pretend to be black
is because of the social advantage
and they they even admit that in so many
words when they're exposed
um and in other words
systemic racism is a ridiculous fable
that that's what we learned from this
you know uh in fact it's strange when
you think about it because in our
country
white people pretend to be black men
pretend to be women straight people make
up
all kinds of different labels so they
can count themselves as lgbt
and and yet we're told
black people women and lgbt people are
oppressed
but these are the groups that outsiders
are desperate to be a part of
that's not the way it works when you
really have an oppressed group
if a group is really being oppressed in
society you wouldn't have
non-members doing everything they can to
pretend to be
members that's a very clear and basic
uh conclusion we could draw from that
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation
today we're going to cancel airlines so
if you're on a plane right
now as you listen to this i'm sorry for
the inconvenience but your plane is
cancelled
mid-flight the reason is the whole
series of arbitrary and unnecessary
precautions they've taken because of
covid
which i got a good taste of last week
flying across the country to and from
it starts really in the airport so the
airports are also cancelled so is tsa
for many reasons not just this one
but now you know you go up to tsa now
at least at lax and baltimore i don't
know about the other airports but
and they don't check your ticket this is
part of the covid safety plan
they look at your id but they don't look
at your ticket now how does not scanning
the ticket
protect from covid who knows well i do
know it doesn't
the whole reason they did check our
ticket at security is for safety
allegedly it was needed to stop
terrorists from getting on the planes
because terrorists i guess wouldn't know
how to book an airline ticket
even though the airline the 911
terrorists were all ticketed passengers
but anyway um well are we thinking that
the terrorists are going to take a break
now because of covid
or was the ticketing the ticket checking
step never necessary to begin with
if it wasn't why did they ever do it if
it was necessary why aren't they doing
it now
these questions can't be answered
speaking of unanswerable questions
as you walk through the airport whole
sections are taped off randomly
why because of covid you can't sit here
in these chairs
but you can sit over there in those
chairs
it's not like this is going to help
people space out the opposite effect now
people
now you're just condensing people even
more um
so why can't you sit in in these chairs
but you can sit in those chairs
is there some sort of force field around
the acceptable chairs
has a gypsy cast a magical spell on
those chairs protecting the sitter from
kovid
do gypsies even cast magical spells or
am i thinking of wizards
again nobody can answer these questions
then as you get as you board the plane
you get yelled at if you're too bunched
together you know you have to maintain
your social distance as you board the
plane
yes the group of 75 people about to
enter a narrow metal tube
and spend the next six hours sitting
next to each other while breathing
recycled air
must make sure not to come within six
feet of each other prior to that
experience
why then you're on the plane um the
flight attendant whose full-time job now
is just to tell you to keep your mask on
informs you that there will be no
beverage service
well they could serve water but not
alcohol and this is terrible for me
because i had a coupon for a free
alcoholic beverage
that isn't the point though well that's
kind of the point but but also
why would serving beer present greater
risk of viral transmission than serving
water
i mean you're walking through the plane
with a with a tray of plastic cups
filled with water
as everybody's breath germs settle on
top of the water like like
muck on a pond a beer would be in a can
wouldn't an alcoholic beverage in a
closed container be safer if anything
than a cup of water
if anything shouldn't they only be
serving beer and whiskey
in fact shouldn't they require that we
drink it
i'm not sure why they would require it
but that would be fun also
i should note that some people
apparently think that the fact that
everybody is wearing a mask on the plane
is an invitation for them to discharge
their intestinal fumes at will
somebody on my plane i can say was
farting
with reckless abandon my mask
stood no chance against this somebody
else was eating some sort of garlic dish
okay farts and garlic it was like being
in the worst
scented candle shop in existence and i
haven't even told you about the guy
next to me who lifted his mask up to
cough
okay every time he coughed he would lift
his mask up and then cough into the
into the wide open air a real concept
problem here okay i started to wonder if
our plane crashed would this guy take
his seatbelt off right before impact
like if masks serve any function then
it's definitely most
valuable and necessary precisely when
you cough other people uh were doing the
opposite though refusing to take the
mask off for any reason
people were eating with the mask on
because they did give us little snacks
you can't have beer but you have snacks
they were feeding themselves by lifting
the mask and inserting the cracker
underneath the mask it was like i was at
asylum watching hannibal lecter at
feeding time and
i should mention that except for the one
guy already noted everybody else kept
their masks on
over their nose for the whole flight
baltimore and california and in the
flight back as well
i was the only one that i saw that i
taken my mask off every chance i got
i got yelled at by the flight attendant
like three times um
everybody else for like for five hours
five six hours they just kept the thing
on
no fidgeting no apparent discomfort
total
obedience everybody on fight with the
thing over their nose the entire time
i felt like i was seeing the end result
of some sort of insidious social
experiment which
i was but as far as the precautions go
all of it is arbitrary and that's the
case everywhere not just on flights
why do so many places have 10 p.m
curfews now you know
like bars and restaurants aren't open
past 10 in a lot of places because of
covet
does the virus transmit more easily at
night are there coveted zombies that
come out in the dark like an i am legend
no but all of this is similar really to
the lap bars on roller coaster rides
is that little bar across your lap gonna
gonna keep you in place when the roller
coaster is zipping around no
inertia does that but the lap bar just
makes you feel better
it's for show essentially that's
actually what everything at tsa is
always about
even before covet i mean one guy tried
to sneak onto a flight with a bombing
issue
and now billions of travelers have to
take off their shoes when they go
through security forever with that kind
of logic they shouldn't be flying planes
at all one crash should have been enough
to shut the whole thing down
but the logic isn't logic it's pageantry
it's theater
it's designed to make you feel better
and also to control you
and personally i'm tired of it i'm sick
of it i'm done with it
i hate it being on a plane is miserable
enough and now with the mask it's even
worse
so cancellations all around to everybody
involved
um well this and and even when this is
all over there
still just cancellations to everybody
just just purely out of frustration on
my on my part
and we'll leave it there for today uh
remember
this show will soon only be available on
my youtube channel uh
so go to youtube.com matt walsh
that's youtube.com matt walsh go do that
go do that right now i demand it
right now um
sorry to yell you i'll talk to you
tomorrow godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton